احدى اسخن البقاع على الارض تدور حرب
بارده جديده بين روسيا والولايات المتحده
حرب مدفوعه للسلاح والذهب وحتى وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي لتوسعه النفوذ وملا
الفراغ الذي خلفه الفرنسيون في تشاد حضرت
واشنطن الرئيس محمد ادريس ديبي مؤخرا من
ان المرتزق الروس يخططون لقتله مع ثلاثه
من كبار مساعديه وان موسكو تدعم المتمردين
تشاديين المحتشدين في جمهوريه افريقيا
الوسطى المجاوره
وقت نفسه تغازل موسكو المتعاطفين داخل
نخبه الحاكمه في تشاد بمن فيهم الوزراء
والاخ غير الشقيق للرئيس
وفقا لصحيفه نيويورك تايمز قرار الحكومه
الامريكيه مشاركه معلومات استخباراتيه
حساسه مع رئيس دوله افريقيه ياتيك احد
التكتيكات الجديده التي تتحرك بها اداره
بيض لافشال المكاسب الروسيه في افريقيا
كذلك التحرك الامريكي ياتي استباقا للتمدد
روسيا في المستعمرات الفرنسيه السابقه مثل
مالي وجمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى بعدما تخلت
عنه حيث تمثل محاوله اغتيال الرئيس وتنصيب
اخيه غير الشقيق فصلا جديدا من جهود قوه
فاغنر لتوسعه النفوذ الروسي سواء بالقتل
او بتراخيص استخراج الماس والذهب
خلال العام الماضي وفيما يشبه التسابق بين
الجانبين كثف مسؤولون امريكيون زياراتهم
الى افريقيا فيما يستعد بايدن للزياره
ايضا هذا العام كان 7 دول في القاره خلال
العام الاخير اذ تؤكد واشنطن سعيا موسكو
لتثبيت اقدامها هناك بدات تظهر في اريتريا
ايضا وعبر مرتزقه فاكتور اقدام يريد
الكرملين ان يخطوا بها بين البحر الاحمر
والمحيط الاطلسي